[Applaudissements]
et si harry palmer même mois merci à
tous d'être aussi nombreux à nous
regarder tous les soirs vraiment vous
êtes plus d'un million à nous regarder à
cette heure-ci avoir guéri bourreau avec
sa chemise rose et ça c'est une vallée
votre t-shirt coeur de lion aussi un
[Musique]
c'est pour lui le bonnet soutenir joie
de cinq ans sachez que je vais en
désigner un tout à l'heure qui va faire
le job je mate avec un bonnet et des
lunettes pour aller sous l'eau
voilà parce que sheryfa luna va faire le
grand plongeon splash alors c'est pas
cette semaine que vous avez démarré la
semaine d'après on va en parler dans un
instant pourquoi vous avez dit oui déjà
pour avoir accepté le grand paul parce
que mon fils concrètement m'a défié donc
à la base j'étais vraiment pas partant
de ce que je ne sais absolument pas
plonger d'accord se plonge le nez c'est
ça ouais voilà donc comme la plupart des
français quoi et monfils en gros m'a dit
tu le feras jamais une flip est d'accord
et en fait il y aurait je le fais donc
j'ai dit ma au club et je vais le faire
tu verras que fut pas une pipette et que
ta mère a décidé vous êtes auprès des
affaires faut commencer seconde direct
oui et vous êtes entrée d oui on s'est
entraîné depuis trois semaines
maintenant ah ouais on tiens moi il me
reste une semaine j'ai déjà 8 de mes
camarades qui seront en direct de minces
mais dites-moi ya eu plus d'accidents
comment ça se fait sipa écoute je pète
pas d'eau dans la piscine ou quoi sans
décoller alors un jeu pensé que déjà il
ya des garçons qui se sont laissés je
pense que les glaces les glaçons les
garçons book concrètes fin mardi les
garçons concrètement je pense qu'ils
veulent faire les dingues et ils se font
très mal quoi vous avez vu que pop star
revenait sur sur des beats
je suis tellement contente d'en c'est
vrai d'ailleurs tout petit petit appel
je rêverais d'être dans le jury de
popstars
bah voilà à peine
voilà au patron de délits ou là il est
où d'ailleurs le patron de devil
faites-moi descendre un patron je vais
lui dire voilà ce serait cohérent
ces normes le gars fait mal et ce en a
pas de bombe a provoqué par la foudre à
ma porte est pas trop je vais lui parler